[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue pour cette nouvelle
semaine d'information locale sur tv
60,18 voici les titres de ce journal du
lundi 9 décembre
cinquième jour de la grève contre la
réforme des retraites résultats des
routes saturées ce matin et un trafic
quasi-nul sur le réseau des transports
en commun demain pas d'amélioration en
vue avec une nouvelle mobilisation
prévue le point dans ce journal
cinq mois après l'incendié de la station
d'épuration d'achères emmanuelle wargon
sur place la secrétaire d'état la
transition écologique et solidaire est
venu constater les dégâts et faire le
point sur l'avancée de l'enquêté
concernant les causes de l'incident
et puis dans cette édition retour sur le
33e téléthon le marathon pour la
recherche contre les maladies et la
génétique rare se tenait ce week-end le
bilan et dans les communes de villepreux
et de maurepas à suivre dans ce journal
on parle de la journée internationale
des droits de l'homme un événement est
prévu demain soir à l'espace la bulle à
l'espace saint quentin de montigny le
bretonneux le cycle astronomie aussi qui
se déroule cette semaine à saint rémy
les chevreuse sans oublier lé résultat
sport de ce week end
plus de 600 km de bouchons cumulés ce
matin en ile de france près du triple de
la circulation habituelle avec le
cinquième jour de grève contre la
réforme des retraites se déplacer
relever du parcours du combattant ce
matin des routes saturées et un trafic
quasi-nul dans les transports et cela
risque de ne pas s'arranger une
mobilisation est prévue demain à paris
la cgt cheminots de versailles réuni ce
lundi matin en assemblée générale à la
gare des chantiers à beauté pour la
reconduit la reconduction de la grève
c'est là à versailles chantiers que
transitent habituellement les lignes n
uds du transilien le rer c'est aussi
qu'ils étaient extrêmement perturbé
encore aujourd'hui postiers enseignants
électriciens et gaziers ont également
participé à la réunion en présence du
député du 93 de la france insoumise eric
coquerel les propos sont recueillis par
manon varaldo je considère
qu'aujourd'hui plus ceux qui se sont mis
en grève et notamment les cheminots
fonderait faut pour l'intérêt général
pour les autres salariés aussi et pour
le pays
donc en tant que député chacun doit être
un peu à son poste voilà le mien c'est
de venir soutenir ses décide répercuter
la parole lorsqu'on donne la donne c'est
d'essayer de me battre à l'assemblée on
sera en grève demain évidemment et pour
peser sur le gouvernement
je pense que le gouvernement va faire
des annonces mercredi qu'ils seront très
en-deça de ce qu'attendent les grévistes
ont la suite je pense même si c'est aux
travailleurs de décider sur leur lieu de
travail dans les assemblées générales la
suite c'est la continuation de la grève
son renforcement et la question de sa
généralisation à tous les secteurs et
puis ma foi s'il faut faire la bûche de
noël sur les piquets en france qu'est la
grève annoncée pour durer alors qu'une
rencontre entre le gouvernement et
plusieurs syndicats s'est tenue
aujourd'hui le premier ministre edouard
philippe doit faire des annonces
mercredi
vous allez le voir avec cette première
animation les perturbations dans les
transports seront sensiblement les mêmes
demain mardi
toujours aucun train sur la ligne u qui
circulent entre la défense et la
verrière pour la ligne n 1 train toutes
les 30 minutes entre rambouillet paris
montparnasse et ceux de 6h à 10h 30 et
de 16h30 à 21h30 autant de trains sur
l'axé plaisir grignon mais sur les
créneaux 6h15 10h30 et 16h 15 22 heures
pour les lignes de rer à présent compter
un train sur deux en heure de pointe sur
le rer à 1 train sur 3 sur le rer b en
notant que l'interconnexion est
interrompu en gare du nord
aucun train ne circulera sur le rer c
entre paris austerlitz et les gares de
saint quentin en yvelines et de
versailles chantiers enfin notez que des
perturbations sont également notables
est visible sur les réseaux de bus sur
skis bus par exemple les lignes
desservant les établissements scolaires
seront assurés en priorité demain
j'ajoute que des écoles du territoire
devrait rester fermée pour la journée de
mardi
voilà ce qu'on pouvait vous dire sur ce
point concernant la grève contre la
réforme des retraites
[Musique]
difficile de se déplacer aujourd'hui
difficile de faire garder votre enfant
aussi à montigny le bretonneux le
personnel de la petite enfance étaient
en grève ce lundi une quarantaine de
personnes s'est réunie ce matin devant
l'hôtel de ville à l'appel de la cfdt à
leurs revendications plus de personnel
selon les grévistes le manque d'effectif
conduirait à des conditions de travail
difficiles et des agents au bord du burn
out la sécurité des enfants qui ne
serait plus assurée de manière optimale
et de son côté la mairie ne conteste pas
le manque d'effectif mais accuse un
déficit de recrutement il ya une pénurie
sur le secteur est de la petite enfance
en ile de france depuis deux ans elle
indique que 81 commission de recrutement
ont donné lieu cette année à trente et
une embauche une délégation syndicale a
été reçue par le maire cet après midi à
laval estime avoir été écouté mais n'est
pas satisfaite pour autant des
propositions de la municipalité une
nouvelle action est donc en cours de
réflexion et dans l'actualité du jour
aussi la visite de l'une des secrétaires
d'état à la transition écologique et
solidaire hr cinq mois après l incendie
de la station d'épuration
emmanuelle wargon s'est rendu sur le
site classé seveso qui est sinistrée un
site géré par le siaap les objectifs
constater les dégâts sur place et
prendre connaissance des avancées de
l'enquète sur les origines de l'accident
le reportage de nicolas d'andré des
débris des escaliers des murs en ruines
les dégâts causés par l'incendié de la
station d'épuration d'achères le 3
juillet dernier
plus précisément sur l' usine c'est
naval de saint germain en laye du siaap
chargée de traiter les eaux usées
six mois plus tard les premiers éléments
émergent suite aux expertises sur les
causes de ce sinistre sur deux cuvettes
en maintenant son cul plus particulière
et visez donc quatre causes possibles
différentes tous d'origine électrique
donc on va patienter le temps que
l'espère du de l'assurance puisse aller
au bout de sa mission
actuellement une installation provisoire
fonctionne pour traiter les eaux usées
pour comprendre et tirer les
conséquences trois audits sont en cours
emmanuelle wargon secrétaire d'état
auprès de la ministre de la transition
écologique et solidaire est venu
constater les dégâts et échanger avec
les parties prenantes
on a lancé de façon très sérieuse toutes
les procédures permettant d'aller au
bout des causes est au bout de
l'amélioration des mesures de précaution
et de prévention
après il manquait un plan de prévention
et d'information des habitants qui sera
validée d'ici quelques jours
probablement d'ici la fin de l'année
et du coup ça permettra d'engager une
discussion plus structurée avec les
riverains sur quoi faire il faut
prévenir et mettre tout en oeuvre pour
que les mesures préventives de sécurité
empêche totalement je dirais une
catastrophe
c'est là-dessus véritablement qui vont
mettre le paquet pour éviter que l'on
passe au niveau pp c'est à lèvres c'est
trop tard
une nouvelle réunion de suivi doit avoir
lieu fin janvier début février avec les
premiers résultats des audits avec
peut-être les raisons de cet incendie
sur ce site industriel avec plus de 74
millions d'euros au compteur les
promesses de dons de la 33e édition du
téléthon sont en hausse au niveau
national dans les yvelines plusieurs
manifestations ont eu lieu aux quatre
coins du département notamment à
maurepas et villepreux ont fait le point
avec aurélie rond et mélanie poker n des
animations pour la bonne cause
le monde associatif maurepas siens
étaient mobilisés pour cette 33e édition
du téléthon
plusieurs initiatives étaient proposées
au public au gymnase de la malle me
donne
alors entre
donnez l'argent médecin qui sera récolté
les temps
de médicaments
j'ai une amie qu'un enfant myopathe et
je suis particulièrement
sensibiliser arts martiaux gymnastique
ou encore initiation handfauteuil une
opération de solidarité qui réunit
chaque année de nombreux bénévoles
faut pas croire les bénévoles du
téléthon sont pas forcément des gens qui
sont touchés famille allemand ou
amicalement par par ces maladies mais
par des gens simplement qu'on a envie de
faire quelque chose pour les autres et
particulièrement pour les enfants
[Musique]
changement d'ambiance à villepreux pour
ce téléthon le public a pu faire le
plein de sensations dans des supercars
une animation proposée par le moto club
de philippe roche et c'est l'occasion de
première en dehors de faire partager
notre passion de pouvoir faire
bénéficier à toute personne d'avoir
l'occasion de monter dans une super
carte on a des occasions de monter
dedans et de rouler avec
avec ces baptêmes mis leur ont ainsi pu
être récoltés en faveur de la recherche
contre les maladies génétiques
parmi les autres temps forts de cette
33e édition des démonstrations de
capoeira ou encore un défi rameurs de 24
heures
le tissu associatif est très créatif à
on a les artistes qui exposent donc
toutes leurs créations nées plaît plus
de 500 bénévoles je pense depuis un an
pour être à ce week end festif pour le
téléthon avec une fréquentation
supérieure à l'année dernière le bilan
est d'ores et déjà positive pour l'afm
téléthon de villepreux demain mardi 10
décembre c'est la journée internationale
des droits de l'homme qui s'y qui
célèbre la signature de la déclaration
universelle c'était le 10 décembre 1948
à l'onu les droits de l'homme on en
parlera demain à l'espace la bulle il
est situé dans le centre commercial
espace saint quentin à montigny le
bretonneux on en parle avec deux invités
françois de sales de l'air dont soir
dans sa tête la présidente dany masseaux
ce qui gère ce lieu culturel non
marchand on aura l'occasion d'en dire
deux mots tout à l'heure et christine
bouvet de good bonsoir ans à membres
militante de l'antenne saint-quentinoise
d'amnesty international ong 1 qui
promeut bien sûr la défense des droits
de l'homme et qui rencontrent donc le
public demain à la bulle d une première
question pour vous pourquoi accueillir
cette association
amnesty international le masque qui nous
intéresse particulièrement amnesty
international mais tous nous intéresse
donc tout projet qui peut être
susciter l'intérêt du public passant
parce que c'est un public particulier
quand même qu'on accueille dans la bulle
tout projet voilà mérite d'être
accueilli dans la bulle et la bulle est
fait pour ça chaque 10 décembre c'est la
journée internationale des droits de
l'homme quels sont les objectifs de
cette journée
alors cette journée d'abord je remercie
encore françoise vous avoir à payer la
bulle demain c'est exceptionnel parce
qu'elle a bu louvre plutôt le samedi
donc elle ouvre à mardi 10 décembre pour
fêter en effet pour proposer aux gens qu
de se renseigner de s'informer sur la
déclaration universelle des droits de
l'homme leur rappeler que l'on peut agir
quand on peut se renseigner s'informer
agir en signant des pétitions
nous faisons tous les ans au moment de
cette de cet anniversaire une campagne
la plus grande compagnie mondiale en
matière de droits de l'homme qui
s'appelle les dix jours pour signer du 6
au 16 décembre voulu et en lumières dix
personnes dont les droits de l'homme
sont bafoués
c'est un personnes à travers le monde
dit personne ou une association cette
année on a par exemple une association
de jeunes indiens au canada qui cherche
à défendre leurs peuples autochtones
donc des gens qui ont besoin d'être
soutenus par des signatures ou des
pétitions dans leur combat pour les
droits humains
donc c'est de montrer aussi que malgré
voilà on a 71 ans après la signature de
cette déclaration universelle il reste
encore forte à faire
il reste forte à faire et il faut qu'on
comprenne que nous ici on peut faire
quelque chose et qu'on peut en écrivant
et en signant des pétitions faire bouger
les choses et on pourra montrer demain
aux gens par exemple tous qui a réussi
l'année dernière
et comment on améliorer le sort de
beaucoup de personnes grâce à ses
campagnes donc demain à la halle au clan
ça sera un événement lié aux droits de
l'homme
la bulle en propose d'autres quelle est
la vocation justement de ce lieu qui a
rouvert depuis octobre à l'espace saint
quentin alors on est très contents que
le groupe hammerson est accepté de
reconduire cette partenariat puisque
c'est un projet extrêmement innovant ça
n'existe nulle part ailleurs un lieu
comme ça qui est organisée gérer et
ensuite proposé aux associations et aux
acteurs locaux culturels comme amnesty
mais ça va de la musique au théâtre en
passant par la danse en passant par des
ateliers de l'économie sociale et
solidaire le respect de l'environnement
c'est extrêmement large avec des
horaires d'ouverture élargis
cette année ça avec des horaires
d'ouverture cadré c'est à dire tous les
samedis et maintenant le mercredi
après-midi en plus et des temps
exceptionnels comme de m'asseoir et
comme dimanche après midi où nous ferons
aussi une ouverture exceptionnelle pour
un autre événement on trouve toutes les
infos sur le site dany masseaux ce le
programme de demain juste pour terminer
ce programme de demain on aura un petit
partage avec les gens qui seront à
l'intérieur d'eux qu'ils rentreront à la
bulle pour voir avec eux qu'est ce qu'il
pense des droits humains est ce qu'ils
les connaissent ce qu'ils savent les
cités ou en citer quelques-uns
et puis après on leur proposera de
prendre connaissance des dix personnes
et des associations qu'on défend cette
année pour signer des pétitions ou bien
écrire aux personnes sachant que ça le
ça leur fait énormément de bien de
savoir qu'on pense à eux
de l'autre côté du monde et le rendez
vous est fixé à partir de 18h45 à
l'espace la bulle au sein du centre
commercial espace saint quentin
merci françois de sales de l'air et
merci à vous christine nouvelle goutte
pour amnesty international elle est
examiné depuis aujourd'hui par les
députés à l'assemblée nationale la loi
anti gaspillage pour une économie
circulaire a été adoptée en septembre au
sénat la sénatrice des yvelines martha
de sidrac rapporteur du texte a fait de
la pédagogie dans le département réunion
en novembre puis visite d'un site et
début décembre pour montrer concrètement
l'application notamment sur le sujet des
déchets et des plastiques manon varaldo
martha d'ci drague sénatrice des
yvelines et rapporteur de la loi
gaspillage économie circulaire organisé
une réunion autour de cette loi adoptée
au sénat est examiné à l'assemblée
nationale une loi autour d'un certain
nombre de dispositifs qui concerne plus
spécifiquement les élus locaux et les
territoires en premier chef
ce sera essentiellement autour bien
évidemment des déchets et des dépôts
sauvages puisqu'on a un vrai sujet dans
notre département mais également sur
tout ce qui concerne les plastiques en
hors foyer les usages que l'on fait
selon les régions nous n'avons pas
toujours les mêmes codes couleurs pour
les poubelles le texte permettra
d'uniformiser cela un objectif partagé
il ne s'agira pas pour les collectivités
d'investir dans de nouvelles poubelles
parce que vous imaginez le coude
l'idée c'est de trouver un code qu'il
soit partagé par nous tous et qui soit
le même dans toute la france
martha de cidre ac est revenu sur les
bouteilles en plastique et le logo
inscrit dessus le point vers les usagers
pensent en grande majorité qui signifie
que le produit acheté et recyclables ces
faux qui ne font pas induire nos
consommateurs en erreur
il faut leur donner la bonne information
et c'est le sens de deuxième logo dont
on a parlé ce matin qui est le tri man
et chivu stipule très clairement si un
produit doit être triés et donc
potentiellement recyclé derrière martha
dos idrac s'est rendu à l'usiné france
plastique de recyclage de limay où sont
reconnaissables des bouteilles de notre
usage quotidien
le recyclage des produits de
consommation courante c'est un des
volets de la loi gaspillage économie
circulaire
ces plastiques vont évidemment être
introduit dans l'installation qui est à
côté de nous qu'ils vont subir tout un
système tout un procès ce qui de déchets
plastiques tel que nous le voyons ici
vont devenir en fait des paillettes qui
vont être incorporées dans des produits
finis et qui vont de nouveau être
réinjectés dans le commerce le but avoir
une durée pour ses produits la plus
longue possible en l'airé introduisant
de nouveaux dans une filière qui n'est
pas forcément celle du produit d'origine
le gouvernement affiche un objectif de
100 % de plastique recyclé pour 2025
[Musique]
ce qu'il faut retenir des résultats
sport du week-end avec nickel et demi
d'euros bonsoir la rédaction de tv 78 on
commence par du football
on jouait la coupe de france jouée ce
week-end le 8e tour de la compétition
versailles dernier représentant évinois
encore en course va continuer l'aventuré
et versailles ont réussi à s'imposer 3
buts à 0 sur le terrain de virer
l'équipe qui évolue également en
nationale 3 les trois buts ont été
inscrits par l'attaquant yoan akassou on
écoute l'entraîneur de versailles
youssef chebbi qui retient avant tout
l'état d'esprit une compétition
particulière ou puis en avant d'un pue
ça devient difficile et plus on a besoin
de deux de valeur comme comme le courage
de l'abnégation la solidarité pour
pouvoir franchir les paliers et
aujourd'hui en termes de cohésion et
solidarité
mon équipe a franchi un pas et
aujourd'hui voilà le résultat de ce
travail de ce parcours puisque on a six
matchs cette saison de coupe de france
et si qualification consécutive cette
qualification est une première en dix
ans pour les verts c'est lié au prochain
tour versailles pourrait affronter un
club de ligue 1 au mois de janvier le
tirage au sort aura lieu ce soir greg
grégory on espère voir pourquoi pas un
versailles psg mickaël versailles
marseille au stade mont boron le centre
de versailles également du volley ball
au programme ce week-end un match pour
rester dans la course à la montée vélizy
recevez saint-avertin les derniers du
classement pour le compte de la 7ème
journée de nationale 3 bien en place
tactiquement les béliziens remporte les
deux premiers sets sur le score de 25 22
et 25 21
dans le troisième set les joueurs de
florent guillossou sont plus en
difficulté il arrive finalement à
l'emporter 29 à 27 après avoir failli
concéder le set bilan de cette rencontre
trois sets à zéro sur le troisième set
un réveil de l'équipe adverse il nous a
pas facilité la tâche qui a bien servi
nous on a fait des petites des petites
erreurs un peu un peu bête et ballon qui
tombe sans que personne se jettent
dessus c'était compliqué on a su à la
fin resserrer les vis cette victoire
permet à l'équipe d'occuper la troisième
place du classement avec un bilan de
cinq victoires en sept journées
disputées des résultats qui permettent
au club de regarder vers le haut du
classement
grégory merci michael ces résultats bien
d'autres choses encore dans votre
émission le 7-8 sport c'est à suivre
après ce journal le dossier de la
rédaction à présent dédié en ce dernier
mois de l'année aux personnalités de
2019 dans les yvelines
en sport justement michael vous nous
proposer ce soir le portrait de quentin
lafargue le pistard de l'équipe de
france le sportif licencié au club
d'elancourt saint quentin en yvelines le
vélo-club d'elancourt saint quentin en
yvelines a remporté trois titres majeurs
cette saison des performances qui
devrait le conduire aux prochains jeux
olympiques on regarde ce sujet avec les
images de patrick jacques de dixmude à
quentin lafargue c'est l'histoire d'une
mécanique bien rodée le pistard a
commencé le vélo à l'âge de 12 ans dans
une école de cyclisme en gironde
c'était en 2003 sur le vélodrome de
bordeaux comme tous les jeunes j'ai vite
quelques résultats et
ça m'a surtout beaucoup plus toutes les
épreuves liées au sprint à la vitesse
j'avais un gabarit assez un corpulent
quand j'étais plus jeune et surtout plus
court plus corpulents que les autres et
du coup je prenais beaucoup de plaisir à
faire des disciplines de sprint
aujourd'hui quentin lafargue à 29 ans il
côtoie un autre vélodrome le national à
saint-quentin-en-yvelines
c'est ici que le sportif décroche ses
premiers résultats sur la scène
internationale en 2016 la tête remporte
l'or sur le km lors des championnats
d'europe en 2015 première médaille sur
un championnat du monde avec le bronze
en vitesse individuelle
c'était vraiment le dernier sprint du
championnat après moi ans ils ont éteint
les lumières presque donc voilà c'est
une vraie
enfin une vraie belle image mon genre
genre tiens énormément d'émotion et
voilà 6000 personnes qui crient pour te
faire pédaler un tout petit peu plus
vite c'est voilà je n'oublierai jamais
ça 2015 une année particulière mais 2019
restera une année unique pour quentin
lafargue le sportif a remporté cette
année trois titres trois médailles d'or
sur le kilomètre lors des mondiaux les
championnats d'europe et de france
une très belle saison 2010 9 sur
laquelle physiquement j'ai montré que la
progression qu'en fin suivait son cours
et est en tout cas qui donne beaucoup de
confiance pour la suite ça faisait
quelques années qui tournait autour
autour du cou et je dirais que cette
année elle ait été l'année de la
consécration de de cantat mais ça fait
quand même quelques années qu'on consent
planter un peu fermé des grands
résultats
des résultats qui permettent à son
équipe le vélo-club elancourt
saint-quentin-en-yvelines team vous sert
d'avoir un rayonnement international
quant à la fin car rejoint cette
structure en novembre 2018
c'est une fierté c'est une fierté c'est
exceptionnel c'est quelqu'un de humble
humble et porté vers la jeunesse
un exemple quentin lafargue espère
maintenant décrocher son billet pour les
jeux olympiques de tokyo l'année
prochaine en espérant que 2020 soit une
aussi belle année que 2019 à léon par la
tête dans les étoiles pour refermer ce
journal avec mes deux invités qui
viennent nous présenter un cycle
astronomique est organisée en fin de
semaine dans la ville de saint rémy les
chevreuse florence doit ce bonnet
bonsoir pense à vous êtes la responsable
des affaires culturelles dans la commune
et bonsoir ça rentiers vous êtes
originaire de voisins-le-bretonneux
chercheuse au sein à du laboratoire
astroparticule et cosmologie de
l'université paris diderot vous allez
animer une conférence sur les ondes
gravitationnelles elle sera grand public
on en parle tout à l'heure et pour ceux
qui ne s'en souviennent pas vous étiez
passé l'an passé en plateau justement
pour parler voilà de votre prix l'oréal
unesco vous avez été lauréat de ce prix
en 2018 bienvenu merci d'être avec nous
déjà ce cycle qui est organisé du 12 au
15 décembre à l'espace jean racine à
l'espace jean racine pardon pourquoi
organiser ce cycle alors l'objectif pour
la ville de saint rémy les chevreuse et
de faire vivre vraiment
notre espace culturel l'espace jean
racine sur des propositions transversale
avec différentes disciplines
ceci que l'astronomie ce qui nous
intéressait c'était de mettre en valeur
à la fois la culture scientifique qui
est très importantes en vallée de
chevreuse
avec aussi l'université d'orsay le
plateau de saclay qui n'est pas loin et
donc nous avons inauguré le 28 juin
dernier une nouvelle salle d'exposition
et de conférence qui s intitule la salle
marie-curie notamment en honneur à une
femme à une femme scientifique et qui a
un lien avec l'histoire de ces messieurs
heureuse puisque pierre et marie curie
venait régulièrement à saint rémy les
chevreuse en villégiature il a vu une
maison dans un des quartiers proches de
la gare puisque déjà à l'époque la ligne
de chemin de fer bénéfices qu'elles
saint-rémy-lès-chevreuse donc cette
nouvelle salle d'exposition et de
conférence nous permet de proposer à la
fois des expositions des conférences
sarr entier farfar sera notre première
intervenante première conférence hier
sur donc un sujet d'astronomie nettoie
les aînés gravitationnelle on aura
l'occasion d'en parler après et du coup
à part cette conférence
cette conférence je vais y arriver c'est
la fin de ce journal qu'est-ce qui est
qu'est-ce qui est prévu au programme de
ce cycle gastronomie au programme de ces
quatre jours également une
exposition d'astrophotographie donc
surtout sur des galaxies très lointaines
de très beaux clichés à découvrir dans
la salle d'exposition où aura également
lieu la conférence de sart entier et
puis ça c'est jeudi soir jeudi 12
décembre la conférence à 20 heures 30 et
l'exposition dure du vendredi jusqu'à
dimanche donc à l'espace mont racine
dans cette salle marie-curie
ce sont des photographies de julien
bourdette qu'il ya un astrophotographe
amateurs mais passionnés la qualité de
ses clichés sont vraiment magiques et en
complément d'arcueil également la
compagnie dédale musique qui propose un
spectacle qui s'appelle symphonie d'une
nuit sans étoiles
donc il parle des origines de l'univers
on compare vraiment également dans le
cosmos et c'est un spectacle tout public
très familial qui nous permet de partir
dans un univers artistique avec du
théâtre de la musique et de la vidéo il
ya une comédienne sur scène ya des
projections vidéo avec des animations
vidéos qui ont été faites pour vraiment
embarqué le public et puis à la création
musicale aussi s'est porté par une
compagnie qui est plutôt dans la musique
la création musicale va aussi faire
décoller en fait notre public et les
embarquer dans cette histoire des
origines de l'univers avec une course
poursuite
c'est vraiment très grand public quelque
chose est à la fois ça permet de faire
voyager chacun à travers ce spectacle
est donc l'objectif d'un cycle pour pour
nous c'est vraiment d'avoir différentes
portes d'entrée on serait très heureux
si effectivement le public ce dimanche
j'avais envie de venir voir des photos
mais finalement pourquoi pas en savoir
un petit peu plus est resté sur la
conférence
et puis voyager aussi me faire embarquer
à travers un spectacle alors les ondes
gravitationnelles on va tenter en deux
minutes d'en parler ça fait très rapide
sarah entier connecter aux autres
gravitationnelle déjà sur l'aspect grand
public ça c'est important pour vous de
vulgariser justement ses connaissances
ou grand public c'est très important de
faire partager ma passion de
l'astronomie le métier de chercheur qui
est vraiment de s'investir sur des
recherches avec des temps longs et donc
l'astronomie c'est vraiment peut-être
pour moi une science
tout le monde a accès puisqu'il suffit
il suffit de lever les yeux au ciel pour
avoir accès au ciel et ce qui est
intéressant dans ma recherche c'est
qu'on ali l'astronomie et la physique
d'accord et ses grands collaboration
qu'ils sont ensemble pour découvrir les
mystères de l'univers et que vous avez
parlé des ondes gravitationnelles qui
sont un peu une nouveauté en fait depuis
2015 on a capté le premier finale et ça
ça permet de mieux comprendre les
phénomènes violents de l'espace sur
lesquels vous travaillez c'est un cinéma
une violence c'est à dire des collisions
de trous noirs des étoiles à neutrons et
ma conférence appelle connectez-vous aux
ondes gravitationnelles puisque quand on
a une phénomène ultra violent il peut y
avoir de la matière qui est éjecté et
qui rayonne et c'est cette matière qu'on
peut apercevoir avec les télescopes avec
un réseau télescopes dans le monde
entier qui s'appelle grandes maps que
c'était scop très précis qui il faut en
fait l'idée c'est que les engrais et à
ce tunnel comme on a dit ce sont des
phénomènes violents qui apparaissent
n'importe quand et n'importe où sur le
ciel et ça fait un phénomène lumineux
qui disparaît en quelques heures et donc
d'avoir un réseau de télescopes comme
comme cela en fait on peut essayer de
trouver ce signal lumineux et de le
suivre à pendant ces premières 48 heures
rien alors que c'est important vous
militez sur un projet depuis le début de
l'année c'est de connecter à ce réseau
de télescopes professionnels des
astronomes amateurs c'est ça qui peuvent
aussi fournir des informations
exactement donc l'année dernière j'étais
venu sur ce plateau pour promouvoir ce
projet et et en un an
en fait on a eu 40 astronomes amateurs
de partout dans le monde
aussi des canadiens des néo-zélandais
qui nous ont rejoints et qui qui suivait
avec nous les ondes gravitationnelles
mais pour en savoir plus il faut se
rendre à votre conférence un qui se
déroule jeudi à 20h30 et aussi à tout le
cycle d'astronomie il faut s'inscrire
pour venir on peut venir directement sur
place
alors on peut venir directement pour
l'exposition et pour la conférence de
sarah entier toutes les informations sur
le son sur le site de l'asie et pour le
spectacle par contre vous pouvez
réserver ou vous présenter trois quarts
d'heure avant donc c'est vendredi 13
décembre à 20h30 et on a également une
représentation scolaire parce que l'on à
une saison qui est très riche
toute une plaquette il ya coup également
désolé on arrive vraiment derrière fin
de ce journal on a largement dépassé mon
réalisateur n'est pas très contents
alors aux régions l'indiquent
je suis désolé en tout cas on retrouve
toutes les informations sur le site
internet merci à vous deux d'être venu
en parler sur ce plateau voilà c'est la
fin de ce journal merci de l'avoir suivi
belle soirée à tous sur tv 78
[Musique]